cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now first time
back in the studio with us glad to see
you uh
we know that the numbers are going down
here in the united states but i want to
talk about india for a moment
new variant there should we be
tracking using more resources to track
new variants
and ensure that they get vaccines and
more of it
we have no choice i mean we literally
have no choice but to track vaccines we
announced yesterday
a new consortium of tony blair institute
oxford and our institute
which is literally going to track
vaccine i mean variants around the globe
we need to know what is happening in
real time so we can prepare for new
vaccines potentially new boosters
and also obviously with travel
restrictions and where to get the
vaccines the more people we vaccinate
the less more variants are going to come
but also we have to help people around
the globe
it's horrible what's going on in india
right now it is pretty remarkable to
think that here in the united states at
least a third of the population
is now fully vaccinated that said it
does seem like there is a significant
portion of the population that will
choose
not to be vaccinated at all what are the
implications of that
the more the virus spreads the more it
can change and more variants we'll have
here and at the same time there's a
significant portion of the u.s
population that cannot respond to a
vaccine
they have cancer and autoimmune disease
they're too young
and we have to protect them so it's like
the second hand smoke
argument you could smoke all you want
but you can't smoke in a restaurant
because you can harm somebody else
if you don't get vaccinated you can harm
somebody else and we really all have to
stand up for each other and push or
we're going to be in trouble here
i really hope we can break that 70
percent that president biden
really pushed for as a goal for july 4th
how realistic is that we're at 45
i think right now you always have to
bring it down to earth come on
positive here my job it's my job
we're clipping at about two and a half
million vaccines a day and so i hope we
stay there
the approval this week of 12 and older i
think is going to make a big change
they're about 17 million kids 12 to 15.
so if we can really work together and
get vaccinated and do it with data and
overcome the fears what is that what is
that key to getting people to buy
in is there something that we're seeing
that you can do you know i think pfizer
filing for a full there's a there's a
notion there it's an experimental
vaccine which it's not but
the full filing of pfizer or two days
ago is critical
right that means there's a six month
follow-up of data and
believe me i've seen the data it's not
secret the data are great
and so that will get full approval and i
think that will help and it's just
telling people and them understanding
the data you can't force someone to get
vaccinated
but you can really explain the data in a
cogent way to know that the risk of the
virus
dwarfs any risk of the vaccine yeah the
roll out of this
it's possible children 15 and younger
could get the vaccine it seems to be
taking a while how soon how soon because
i'm
among those parents itching to get it
but then
even younger than 12 how soon could we
see this so the next group will be age
five to twelve
and those studies are ongoing now i've
looked at the data they look
very safe my real hope is we can do that
everyone is saying by fall but i hope we
can do that by mid-summer
and then uh six months and older after
that
six months on older will be different
because we don't yet know the dose
that's going to probably be the first
group
we have to change the dosing for and as
we saw in the prior story
it's going to be a fraction of what
adults get and so we don't know the
exact dose so it's going to take longer
testing
but we have to vaccinate more kids 25
percent of the us population is under
the age of 21.
dr vegas it's been 14 months good to see
you sir
february 29th my last time here i know
that's right nice having you back thanks
again
thank you guys